everybody on Kristian harloff and I'm
Tiffany Smith our guest today she
screamed she yell she does God knows
what it is we thank you so much for
joining us and completing the threesome
now I know that you have been at
Montreux recently for the Just for
Laughs festival what else you've been up
to I don't do anything I stay in my
apartment holder though I was I'm gonna
crack this shell I want to know what
you've been up to - because you have a
very popular YouTube channel I do what's
the last thing you filmed by yourself in
your apartment well I did not air it why
what was it tell us are we doing
exclusive do you want me to reenact it
yes I'm very nervous I'm not wearing the
appropriate underwear for that because
that's like you said every week we do a
weekly wager and we put our bucks on the
line to see who can guess the closest to
the box office numbers and we did one
last week on Mission Impossible rogue
nation you bet 51 million and you bid 45
million the actual number is fifty five
point five million dollars which means
we're getting an awesome hashtag loser
should comments we got one from Rick
Smith that says the loser should have to
wear a silly hat for the whole episode
can you say the name of the person in
Rick Smith that sounds like a relative
let's move on to this week's weekly
wager done Fantastic Four's let's check
out a clip
you should use these powers to help
people
what a surprise
they show it a fake I'm gonna say that I
think Fantastic Four is gonna make 41
million and I'm really confident because
the actual Fantastic Four is backing me
yes
hi I'm going to pick 42 cuz that is a
villainous thing to do and I have dr.
doom himself backing me right dr. doom
yeah Christian you're a loser Cobra just
called me a loser
I think he's backing me too Frenchy it's
cold outside oh he should not be having
fun we need a second punishment okay
Amanda Murray senton loser should have
to eat six cupcakes and the winner gets
to decide the time and you made
Fantastic Four cupcakes oh well hello
you've got 60 seconds we're gonna speed
it up in post though so it only be three
seconds on the episodes what a
punishment I can't believe I have to eat
cupcakes ready go send your loser
shoulds because Christians gonna have to
do so we ridiculous again next week
because he's totally gonna lose the
Fantastic Four weekly wage headlines
let's talk Fantastic Four I didn't
realize there was one made so long ago
by Roger Corman oh yeah in like 1994
yeah it wasn't good but listen there are
other ones made though in 2005 and 2007
same cast Jessica Alba Chris Evans
doesn't I do they both have great butts
take a look at a foot oh that makes
sense though if you think about it
though because this particular version
that they're coming over here is you
just from the trailers dark
I suppose that cartoony they don't want
to associate the same thing they did is
with Batman Robin when the Christopher
Nolan vs. come out they don't want
people to associate the other versions I
just don't know
you can remake a film where the
characters are based off of different
STDs but you know it makes sense wait
what it's simple I really wanted people
to get excited about this movie I mean I
should try to show the clip I have a
guest who can enlighten us a little bit
more on Fantastic Four I'm glad to be
this is one of my favorite shows ok so
I'm so excited to have you on the show
to chat with you about Fantastic Four
this new movie definitely has a way more
sci-fi horror vibe to it when you were
creating these characters is that a
theme you really wanted to play with
well as a matter of fact science fiction
always grabbed me as you can tell
listening to me I'm very scientific I'm
very into these intellectual things and
and I love do you have any questions for
Stan would you like to go on a date with
me boy if you had asked me that a few
generations ago what an answer you would
get will have to wait till another life
one last geek out question I have to ask
who would win in a fight the thing or
the Hulk well obviously in a fight let
that rope wait a minute rate that hat I
can't answer I can't see anything but
that that ugly horrible miserable
terrible hat I'm getting out of here
you know you and your father have
embarrassed me here it is called mouth
full we're gonna have movie quotes in
here you guys are going to stick
marshmallows into your face say a movie
quote from a comic book movie whoever I
understand the most wins
come on alright Tiffany's not gonna get
a point
me and the muddled two couple hope is
Tiffany's turned out we know what our
comes no responsibility except that
wasn't true
oh we're not to see I'm just going
straight Marvel try alright almost there
I'm letting the audience know that if
you can win right now
Tiffany wins congratulations you're the
winner she's going to spin the winners
wheel of winning go ahead and spin that
wheel alright okay so since we've been
talking about Fantastic Four I actually
got an exclusive clip and I'm gonna show
it to you guys can't show it
listen you blew it come on Matt note I
want to say a huge thank you for people
joining us for this episode make sure
you guys check out her YouTube page and
while you're here let us know in the
comments below what you think and let us
know some of the guests that you would
like to see complete yes then stick
around and make sure you subscribe to
this channel and download the Fandango
movie clips app on your smartphone and
thank you so much for joining our movie
Oh get out of the way I'm getting out of
here